the siege of Mary upole was a look into
hell
[Music]
for nearly three months the city held
out against a ferocious assault
[Music]
but Mario Paul's story did not end with
his fool Russia is turning it into
Rubble again this time in the name of
reconstruction
for The ukrainians Who call it home
understand a different reason for the
mass demolition an attempt to cover up
war crimes and to erase Ukrainian
identity
bulldozed and transformed into a blank
canvas for plants like these drawn up in
Moscow to turn it into a model Russian
city to be held for decades to come
what's happening in mariupole is the
blueprint for a Ukraine under permanent
Russian occupation
A Story begins thousands of miles away
from the front line here in Northern
Spain Karina gonak had just finished Law
School in Mario upo
wounded she fled for the nepro where
Ukrainian doctors tended to her leg and
from there to North and Spain she was
forced to leave her City and her family
behind
her father was shot dead by a sniper
this is the last picture they took
together
her brother was taken to Russia in an
evacuation bus her mother and
grandmother are still in mariupole we've
blurred their faces for their protection
um
Karina was forced to flee along with
many other former residents of Mary upon
now thousands of miles away here in
Northern Spain she's forced to watch on
as Russia remodels her City
more than two and a half thousand
buildings sustained damage in the
fighting nearly half of everything that
stood in the city
the conflict Observatory a U.S NGO has
used artificial intelligence to map the
extent of the destruction
a city that flourished over 300 years
practically demolished in a matter of
weeks
and they've been busy not repairing
buildings but demolishing them to create
a new city
Russia strictly controls access to the
city but we've been following a trail of
Clues collecting social media posts and
satellite imagery to build up a picture
of what's going on we verified more than
a hundred demolitions or notices of
demolition this represents the most
conservative estimate for the scale of
transformation
each building was once someone's home or
business the most famous was the old
drama theater in the center of the city
in early March Ukrainian civilians were
Sheltering there they wrote the word for
children in huge letters on the road
outside so that it would be visible from
the sky
the airstrike hit in the middle of the
morning hundreds of people are thought
to have been killed
for months it stood as a crumpled shell
but pro-russian journalists have
advertised the local regimes plans to
rebuild it
a facade has been put up around it
decorated with giant portraits of
Russian cultural icons like the writer
Pushkin
ukrainians see a different motive
[Music]
foreign
barely escaped with her life
she lived on 75b Mira Avenue which
translates to peace Avenue it has since
been renamed in honor of Lenin this
satellite image taking just a few days
after the attack on the theater shows
the impact alev Tina and her family were
about to have dinner and went upstairs
to collect some plates when an artillery
strike wiped out the floor below
now her home in the historic Center has
been torn down
[Music]
um
this is the man nominantly in charge of
marayupo Dennis pushlin Stars himself as
the head of the People's Republic of
Donetsk the region that had been under
separatist russian-back control since
2018 until Vladimir Putin declared its
annexation last year
this is a decree signed back in July
it's just a sheet of A4 but it
represents a sharp change in a country's
Heritage and culture
behind it are multiple documents
hundreds of pages long produced by the
Russian government
on the second page it lays bare its
intention to hold the city under Russian
control for the next two decades and
grow the population they either killed
maimed or drove away
they work out it'll take 13 years to get
back to pre-war numbers
flick through the documents a few pages
and page 14 shows the plans for the Old
Town we've taken satellite imagery and
aligned it with the plans
the traditional Patchwork of small
houses that gave the center its
character are ruins and they'll be
replaced by monolithic apartment blocks
we showed all this to Karina
is
it is a pattern being repeated across
mariupo some of the most visible signs
of Ukrainian identity were the first to
be erased even as people still had no
proper shelter just a few hundred meters
up the road from aleftina was a famous
mural of a little girl she lost her leg
and her mother was killed after an
indiscriminate rocket attack on the city
in 2015 launched by Rebel and Russian
forces according to the Ukrainian
authorities
the monument was a symbol of resilience
of Hope to those living in her shadow
but in Autumn it began to be painted
over now there is no Trace Russian
colors have taken her place
it's a similar picture just up the road
we came across this video from a Spanish
Russian influencer yes
she's been filming in the region over
the last few months parts of a
propaganda effort to show the benefits
of Russian rule
if we pause this video post it to
Twitter we can see the city's sign
behind her before it was yellow and blue
the colors of Ukraine this isn't just a
question of history of culture of
identity as important as all those
things are this could be a serious
breach of international law
this does not
um is not in sync with the standards of
international human rights law regarding
cultural rights back in the UK I showed
all this to Professor Alexandra zanthaki
the UN special rapporteur on cultural
rights
I think what is important is that
culture is not used as a form of
[Music]
propaganda and and that in the
post-conflict era cultural heritage is
maintained and revived otherwise we
can't talk about
cleansing an idea of cultural cleansing
and an idea of cultural Warfare this is
the image the local regime wants to put
out new housing Estates happy residents
and Russian Flags everywhere
people are filmed moving in
but even these gleaming new buildings
symbols of Russia's generosity and Care
leave a lot to be desired
recipients
foreign
and people's homes are being demolished
at a much faster rate than they're being
built according to our mapping
in some locations the scale is
breathtaking
every block in this neighborhood in the
east of the city has been demolished
45 buildings in total
or here in the southwest entire regions
demolished new high-rises thrown up in
the middle of what once was a Tranquil
Park
other new buildings are not for civilian
shelter
this a brand new military base
and in the meantime those still
imariable struggle to survive
for all the Russian boasts of
restoration many still live in bombed
out buildings without water without heat
or electricity in the freezing winter
and more immediately than the
Reconstruction they're subject to other
methods of control
in so-called filtration camps like this
residents are questioned by authorities
a method of identifying those who might
pose a threat to the russian-backed
regime schools are being reconstituted
with teachers sent for training in
Russia and Ukrainian textbooks swap for
Russian ones
children have been encouraged to join
military training
um
we asked different Ministries in Russia
and the donets People's Republic for
comment but received no reply
um
Karina is a long way from home but she
is at least safe
her leg is healed thanks to the
Ukrainian doctors who helped her when
she fled
but all she can do is wait who can say
for how long
Northern Spain